[Music]
let's go to
delia in california delia what's up
hi dr dalony how are you so much for
taking my call
thank you so much for calling hey listen
okay listen with as a guy whose last
name rhymes with
an unprocessed i mean just a gross lunch
meat
um i'm all about good name jokes
what's the best name joke you've heard
related to your name
delia um do people say like hey what's
the deal you delia
is that like about as good as it gets i
actually have heard that one once
just once actually most of the time
people say delilah
which surprises me sometimes
delilah is it because they can't read
probably all right so
you have better friends than i do that
you only heard that one time good for
you i need to start hanging out with
better people
all right so what's up delia how can i
help
okay um so
my fiance and i have been together
six and a half years before that we
were like best friends for about four or
five years so we've been in each other's
lives for
10 11 years now um got engaged
october 2019 and four months away from
getting married this october october 9th
which is actually my birthday
october night 2021. happy birthday
um well i don't know we'll see how
um oh okay so we found out
just found out last week that he was
actually seeing someone else
um and i'm very devastated of course
and heartbroken and so did you have no
idea
no it was a complete surprise because
i mean i thought a relationship was you
know
great of course you know we live
together so you have your oh take out
the trash and your little fights here
and there but
it was not i wouldn't say it was a rocky
relationship where i saw anything like
this coming
up i nev it was a complete shocker to me
how did you find out
so last sunday she um
oh this is last sunday like you just
found out just just just found out
yes oh wow okay this is happening right
now
so you're we are live and on scene okay
so last sunday okay go ahead
yes last sunday since we have find my
friends you know on iphones
he was visiting his mom i was visiting
my family
and i was just you know whenever you
head back because we live
together let me head back like let me
know because i'll head back at the same
time
and he lied to me he's like oh like yeah
i'm going to leave soon
um and i look at his location just to
see if he left already but he was
already
in town but somewhere else so i knew he
was you know lying to me about where he
was so that
day i told him like where's you know
where
are you when i'm chanting my calls he
was
he just said okay well we're gonna talk
tonight and then
so sunday we get home and he basically
tells me he has cold feet
but he doesn't say why he doesn't tell
me what he's doing he just says like you
know it's a big step
i don't know if i can be a good husband
and blah blah and it was all just very
huge surprise to me so that night
i was just i had a hunch you know where
is this coming from
and i looked through his phone and
that's when i saw the messages and calls
and
that's when everything came out
wow so there's a lot here
um so what has the last few days been
like
terrible yeah so
i found out and then he told me you know
the truth
that which is good he was
really honest it's also terrible because
just knowing all the details
really hurts so someone he works
with so he would lie about working late
um and they were basically dating each
other you know going out to eat going to
parks
his going over to her place
and yeah and
so these last few days was very
confusing
because one day he said it's over
between me and her like i want to be
with you we're going to get married
we're going to get through this we're
going to make it work and of course
that's what i wanted to hear because i
was willing
to forgive him and do anything we could
go to therapy anything
because i i i love him and i want to be
with him
but then he changed his mind to i'm
confused like i think i need time
for myself and
um then the next day he's back to
um you know we're gonna you're gonna be
my wife we're gonna make this work
and now most recently it's back to
like i need time for myself and
yeah so here's the thing
um you are right square in the middle of
a forest fire
right um
when you how old are you
i'm 25. yeah so this guy's been part of
your life for basically half of it right
yep nearly half and
um you are in full
you are fully limbic right now you are a
fight or flight and you have not even
begun to
feel this thing yet okay and so
um you may have heard me say this a
bunch and i'll just keep saying it
nobody nobody makes good decisions
when they're in the middle of a
firestorm unless they've trained
specifically for that moment
okay so this isn't the moment to decide
i still love him and we're gonna figure
this out this isn't the moment to decide
get out of here this is a moment for you
to grieve
and you gotta grieve right now without
him
giving you his insights and changing his
mind and toggling back and forth because
he's busted and caught
okay and his whole world is coming down
around him too
i cannot wrap my head or i mean whatever
man
that's a whole other conversation uh
maybe i can talk to him someday
but you're gonna have to either separate
yourself from him from
for a season or he's gonna have to move
out for a season
okay but you've been playing house for a
long time y'all have basically been
married for a long time just waiting on
this
um show and
the ceremony and so you're gonna have to
get some time apart from one another can
you can he go
live somewhere else for a season sounds
like you can go live with his mom for a
while right
yeah he actually did move out
okay this yesterday two days ago
yeah um but the thing is i think he's
still talking to her
listen listen listen listen i a
thousand percent guarantee you he is
there is not a doubt in my mind that he
is
a millionth billion percent chance he is
still talking to her
he's probably seen her okay
there is nothing before or since
that would give me any other um
idea okay
yeah and you said
um he came clean and told me the truth
and
about this person he met at work you all
have a relationship this is just in
10 seconds of you explaining this story
to me where you track each other's
phones
you check his phone when he's because
you don't believe him
he's lied about stuff there's some
definite cracks in the foundation of
this relationship
and who knows how long it's been going
on who knows how how
often he's seen somebody else if it's
the first time at the 10th
who knows but right now you got to get
outside of the burning house
okay and what i want you to do is to
take a breather for a minute
and let him know he's not welcome back
in the house for
30 days at the earliest
and i want you to take some time to
actually feel what's going on and
probably that's going to look like you
waking up every day
writing him a letter on how you feel
that day you
pieces son of a i cannot believe you
fill in the blank
i've no and what you're going to do is
you're going to start writing this stuff
out you're going to write down how you
feel what you think about him
what you think about yourself all what
do you think about other women all that
stuff's got to come out
and what you're probably going to
uncover is there's been cracks in this
thing for a long time
it's hard for me to believe as somebody
who's
you've got trust issues with him no
i want to say i didn't but since you're
mentioning the whole tracking
thing there is something that's been in
your heart and mind for a long time
and it may just be that's just the way
guys are or or he just
talks to somebody or he just works later
he just goes and visit
something tells me this doesn't just pop
up
and that's where you got to re you
didn't want to see it you wanted to be
married you wanted to be his wife you
picked this guy out
half your lifetime ago
and if you go mining right if you start
writing this stuff
out and you do it on a regular basis get
somebody with you to talk
about this not someone's just going to
be like oh just forgive him and move on
he's so cute
and not just burn his house down but not
not somebody who will do that because
that's nonsense
right that's just someone who's putting
gas on your emotional fires but
somebody's going to sit there and listen
to you
and poke and prod and go hey we've known
this for a while
or this blows my mind
i really know this guy i think this is a
one-time thing whatev someone who's
going to be honest with you and let you
process openly you may have to pay this
person maybe a
counselor of some sort right but you're
gonna have to get to the bottom of
your feelings underneath the emotions
underneath what's the truth here and
what's the reality and you're gonna have
to have some space and you're gonna
probably cry like you have not cried in
your whole life
and you're gonna ache and hurt like you
haven't ached and hurt
and you need to come up with a picture
of what life might look like four months
from now and you're not married to this
guy
not to say that's gonna happen but you
need to begin to own this might be part
of your future
and you are worth more somebody who's
going to cheat on you and then come back
and say
hey i'm sorry i want to get married in
the next day like you know what i'm out
i like her better and they come back the
next time be like listen
let's play an xbox last night i think
you're the one and then
wakes up the next morning and it's like
you know what i'm just gonna go by and
see her
and then i'm gonna go stay at my mom's
i'll probably see her i mean i'll just
it's cool
it's cool you deserve more than that
delia you deserve more than that
okay he deserves more than that
but it's truth telling honesty time for
you for your relationship
he's got to be gone for a while you got
to get some space in your heart and mind
and your soul
you need to get some wisdom around you
not just someone who is going to bark at
you but just get wisdom around you
you have to start writing stuff down 30
days in a row
how are you feeling what do you think
about yourself what do you think about
him we think about this situation what
do you think about
building a future on a cracked
foundation
you're gonna have to excavate that old
foundation and build something totally
new
happens all the time i can tell you so
many folks
who've had infidelity and long-term
relationships and they go in and heal
they build something new and it is
stronger than before
but i can tell you this you can't build
something strong on dishonesty
you can't build something strong on
tracking each other's phones
and sneaking around lying to each other
and you can't build
something permanent on a damaged
foundation
so delia you have to sit in this for a
bit it's gonna hurt
real bad i'm so so sorry
healing starts today it's gonna be a
long journey
but we'll be thinking about you you get
some folks in your life to walk
alongside you